we begin daleon with Joe Brown - ladies
and gentlemen here's our first and
possibly only official panto guest yes
[Applause]
weirdly I'm not allowed in Who I am the
genie of the Ring cue many jokes about
sphincters just make jokes about there
is a genie of the ring in Aladdin and a
genie of the lamp apparently there are
two genies I didn't even realize that
who else is in it that is that flawless
down the end there
yeah flawless flawless pressure to put
yourself under to call yourselves fall
in the story of Aladdin were they
playing well wait for this they're
playing the Peking police force
[Music]
yeah can we get tickets why I came it's
in Wimbledon from the 6th of December to
the 12th of January Wow now the role you
play the last time this production was
done it was played by Pamela Anderson
yeah who bases a lot of her act or
Mirror costume in your costume and are
you singing and dancing after a fashion
where you do pop songs or do you do
traditional Patra sauce we do actually
we did a mixture of pop songs and
traditional songs so what what are you
doing what are you giving us I'm not
giving a pop song or a traditional song
I'm just at one point I go if I were not
upon the stage something else I'd rather
be if I were not upon the stage a pole
dancer I'd be
that was mine suggesting they vetoed it
oh because of children that woman
doesn't really look like a pole how does
the cow feel about Panthers coach Jeremy
three kids have you dragged them - no
every year - this is where I live in
Chipping Norton there's an amazing
theater there and they put on a
fantastic banter every year but we were
discussing it at work the other day with
the top gear because Richard Hammond is
the sort of person you know he's going
to end up as buttons in the Swindon
library you just talking being in panto
Sharon Osbourne you have given that I
did tremendous work on the story of a
child you did it was it was Richard you
were in fact with Cliff Richard hey aunt
Frank I feel oh wow yes
what were you well I was magnificent as
a pigeon at the Palladium and call him
cuz you trained at the Gaiety so even
those gaze upon toes no I don't think
they're affiliated the school in there
no I never got the call for panto not
yet but christmas is coming up so that's
true working girls crossed
Rob Joseph Inc tourism meant Joe's ring
yeah
yeah I have a slot for you tonight
[Music]
I could be allowed in
with your Beanstalk oh hey we must be I
heard it's more of a salon
[Music]
I had to go on skype with David
Cronenberg so that he could see what my
planned weird sex faces were and so
let's start with you Joe how would you
improve the BBC and I said sac Jeremy
clan said no I'd ban all jokes about
Tampa